Let’s investigate how image intensity varies
along the line that I have shown here in red
and, in particular, let’s focus on what
happens here at the tail of the P. If we look
at the intensity profile here and these pixel
values, these grey scale values are double
precision values that vary between zero for
black and one for white, and we see that it
starts off with a low value of around 0.2.
Whereas on the black paint—the background
of the sign—they rise up to a value of around
0.8 and when we cross the white paint, which
is the tail of the P, and then fall off again
to low background values.
Back onto the black paint: we might be interested
in looking at the horizontal gradient and
we can approximate the gradient as the difference
between a pixel and its neighbour on the left-hand
side—simple numerical approximation to the
gradient. However, this is not a very symmetrical
way to think about this. So instead we can
represent it this way: the intensity in the
horizontal direction of pixel U is the difference
between its neighbour on the right-hand side
and its neighbour on the left-hand side, divided
by 2. This would represent the horizontal gradient.
Now the gradient expressed in this form we
can write as a kernel— it is a small kernel
represented by a 1 by 3 matrix. If we apply
this kernel to the input image the result
would be an output image who’s pixels comprise
the horizontal gradient at the corresponding
point.
Here is an animation similar to ones we have
seen before; in red, we see the input window
marching across the image from left to right
and from top to bottom. As it is moving we
are computing the output values and dropping
them into the output image. Note again that
we are not computing the
left-hand edge and right-hand edge of the
output image because this is where the input
window falls off the input image. We can see
the gradient being computed, we can see areas
of gentle horizontal gradient, we can see
the areas of much stronger horizontal gradient
where we have this continuity and we can see
areas where the gradient is negative.
Let’s apply this to the image that we were
looking at earlier and we can do that quite
simply using the tool box function iconv.
We pass in the first argument, which is the
kernel, and the second argument, which is
the image.
What we can see here is that the left-hand
edges of the letters are coded blue; that
means they have positive gradient that is
where the intensity is changing from the dark
of the background to the white of the letters.
On the right-hand side of the letters where
the intensity falls from white down to the
dark background it has got a negative value
and this is shown as red. So what this kernel
is doing is highlighting vertical lines within
the scene because vertical lines have got
a strong horizontal gradient.
I denote this image as I subscript u (Iu).
This is a common way to denote image gradients.
The subscript represents the direction in
which the gradient is being computed.
Now we can do a very similar thing by rotating
the kernel and now we can compute the gradient
in the vertical direction. So the kernel now
is the transpose of the kernel we used to
compute horizontal gradient. It will allow
us to compute vertical gradient.
Now, we can apply that to our penguin sign,
this is what the kernel looks like and this
is what the output looks like. It has some
similarities to what we saw before. As we
move down in a column, we see that the tops
of letters are blue and this indicates that
they have got a strong positive gradient.
Remember that in images the vertical coordinate
increases downwards. So at the top of a letter
we are moving from the dark background onto
the white paint and so we have a strong positive
gradient. On the bottom of the letters there
is a strong negative gradient if you fall
off the white paint down onto the black background.
So the vertical gradient image has highlighted
the horizontal lines within the image. We
can compute this in MATLAB using almost the
same function as before except we have transposed
the kernel. The kernel is a 1 by 3 matrix
and we use MATLAB’s transpose operator the
quote symbol in order to transpose that kernel
into a 3 by 1 matrix.
A very common kernel used in image processing
is called the sobel kernel, and it has some
similarities to the simple kernel that we
used before. I like to think of this kernel
as computing the horizontal gradient on the
current line and averaging that with the horizontal
gradient on the line above and on the line
below. We can obtain the value of this kernel
using the tool box function ksobel. If I apply
this function to our penguin image I can obtain
a horizontal gradient image that is shown
here, which looks quite similar to the horizontal
gradient we just looked at. The function isobel,
we pass it an image and it returns both a
horizontal gradient image and a vertical gradient
image.
A really important feature in an image—a
very common feature in images of man-made
scenes—are what we call edges. What I am
going to do is to load an image that we have
seen before and to display that, and here
is the sign about penguins again, and what
I am going to do is to look at an intensity
profile along roughly a horizontal line from
here to there, and what we see is the intensity
has got a low value to start with and then
as we cross each of the pieces of white paint
on the sign we see the intensity goes up.
Now let’s zoom in a little bit on that … it
is a little bit too busy. I am going to expand
this region here, which is the beginning of
the word ‘look’, and what we see quite
clearly here is that the pixels have got quite
a low value, less than 0.2 which is the background.
The dark background of the sign moves up to
around 0.6, 0.7. The white paint as we cross
the letter L—down again to a value of 0.2,
and then pixel value increases as we cross
the remaining letters. What we can see is
that as we move from the dark to the light
the intensity increases quite rapidly. Then
it falls quite rapidly on the other side of
the character, so we are going to explore
this idea of gradient or the rate of change
at the grey level as we move horizontally
across the sign.
Often in image processing we are interested
in areas of the image where there is a lot
of gradient. We don’t care whether it is
horizontal or vertical; we don’t care whether
it is positive or negative. We just want to
know where there is a lot of gradient.
And this is computed quite simply by computing
the square root of the sum of the squares
of the horizontal and vertical gradients and
results in an image like this.
Most of it is black because there isn’t
much gradient over the background. Where there
is a lot of gradient around the edges of letters
this function has got a very high value. So
this is a great operator for highlighting
the edges of objects within a scene. And we
can obtain an image like this using the function
isobel with no output arguments.
We might also be interested in the direction
of maximum gradient; in this image pixels
are increasing by a value of 10 every pixel
in the horizontal direction and by 5 every
pixel vertically. So the direction of maximum
gradient change is in this direction, 26°
with respect to horizontal.
Now we can apply that same technique to the
sobel image that we computed before. We can
compute a gradient image and that is the arc
tangent of the vertical gradient image element
wise divided by the horizontal gradient image.
It looks a little bit too busy, so let’s
zoom in on the letter P.
And if we look at the gradient direction on
the left-hand edge of the P, we see that it
has got a gradient direction value of 0. It’s
coded as white.
So if we look at the colour bar over here,
we can see that 0 corresponds to zero radiant
angle and we expect this on this side of the
letter; the gradient is increasing in the
horizontal direction from left to right. On
the other side of the letter the gradient
is, in fact, increasing from right to left
because it is at this point that we are following
from the high white value down to the dark
value. So the gradient is right to left and
we can see on this side of the letter the
gradient angles are either plus π, which
are shown as dark blue or negative π, which
is shown as dark red.